jean marc sylvestre bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors qui dit lutte
contre le corps à la vie russie
recherche d'un vaccin mais également
d'un traitement il faut beaucoup
d'argent est ce que la lumière peut
venir de l'europe selon vous écoutez une
des lumières peut venir de l'europe et
toutes les manifestations qui seront
initiés vous seront bien évidemment les
bienvenues alors l'initiative prise par
la présidente de la commission de
bruxelles a à côté symbolique parce
qu'elle montre effectivement que
l'europe se réveille et il était temps
que l'europe se réveille dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus mais 7000 7 ou 8
milliards d'euros espérés j'espère qu'il
nous obtiendrons surtout que l a
mobilisé la plupart des chefs d'état qui
ont donné leur feu vert évidemment
heureusement elle a mobilisé un certain
nombre de personnalités du showbiz et
l'a d'ailleurs même mobilisé la
fondation bill gates puisque médaille
mais linak budget ça a donné son accord
et son appui à cette opération or elle
est un des acteurs non non négligeable
très important sur la scène mondiale de
la santé donc c'est un signal c'est ça
ne suffira pas mais il faut pas il faut
pas bouder son plaisir quand on voit ce
signal à 7 milliards et demi ça un
objectif réalisable selon vous qui est
susceptible de faire des dons vous avez
parlé de beaucoup de personnalités bill
guesde
du monde du showbiz également est ce que
des dirigeants voilà deux grandes de
grands royaumes pourrait également aussi
participé à cet appel appel aux dons oui
il va y avoir énormément de personnalité
il va y avoir énormément de gouvernants
qui vont mobiliser
mais ce qui va être important c'est de
savoir quelle est la ferveur populaire
pour pouvoir donner un peu comme dans un
internet ont enfin on participe bien à
l'euromillions on va pouvoir participer
à ce à ce que ron arad a t'on mais c'est
pas l'essentiel l'essentiel derrière ces
de déclencher un mouvement en faveur de
la coordination européenne il faudra
évidemment dans un deuxième temps à
rattraper tout le retard que l'europe a
pris l'europe elle est partie
complètement de façon dispersée
elle n'a pas vu l'ampleur de l'est la
gravité de cette contagion
donc on a vu l'italie un peu seul on a
d'ailleurs vu la présidente de la
commission présenté ses excuses à
l'italie
bon alors c'était un premier pas mais il
va falloir dans l'avenir proche se
mobiliser au niveau des budgets
nationaux
parce que il est évident que cette cette
épidémie ne va pas bouleverser l'ordre
du monde dans des conditions importantes
mais elle va sensibiliser des différents
peuples à la nécessité de modifier les
arbitrages budgétaires il va falloir
dans l'avenir investir beaucoup plus
d'argent dans la lutte contre les
épidémies dans la protection de la santé
modifier les arbitrages budgétaires et
coordonner les les budgets robin il n'y
a pas de politique de santé au niveau
européen et nous avons besoin de cette
politique de santé on le voit bien parce
qu'en fait les pays européens commencent
à se parler il commence à se parler pour
pour calais coordonner les dates de
déconfinement on le voit actuellement il
se cale aussi au niveau de la recherche
cette initiative en fait partie mais
c'est pas la seule nous savons très bien
qu'il ya des laboratoires français et
allemands qui sont en train de préparer
un vaccin alors qu'ils le disent
peut-être moins haut et fort que donald
trump ce week-end mais il travaille sur
le fond
et puis il va falloir modifier aussi les
systèmes ou
assurance maladie de façon à mieux
protéger les gens vous avez une au
système d'assurance maladie en europe
qui font l'admiration un peu dans du
monde entier qui sont très protecteurs
participe beaucoup à la guérison au
traitement à la pathologie mais on
participe assez peu avec nos systèmes
d'assurance maladie à la prévention or
cette épidémie n'a à montrer de façon
très claire que les personnalités à
risque les personnes à risque étaient
étaient des personnes qu'on qu'on
connaissait c'était les gens qui sont
victimes d'obésité c'est des gens qu'ils
ont le diabète de maladies cardiaques
c'est des mains des gens qui ont des
conditions de vie ou d'hygiène qui ne
sont pas satisfaisantes
tout ça participe de la prévention et
c'est sur cet aspect là qu'il va falloir
vraisemblablement donné les efforts les
plus importants mais ça c'est du ressort
de chacun des gouvernements qui doivent
être coordonnées au niveau de bruxelles
sa crise mondiale inédite finalement a
montré les faiblesses de l'europe
notamment aux moyens en terme de moyens
financiers pour pour financer ce projet
médical
oui absolument c'est une évidence mais
ya pas de politique de santé européennes
la politique de santé des politiques
nationales étaient liés et est sous la
responsabilité des gouvernements
nationaux et c'était sur la
responsabilité des acteurs nationaux
alors ça faisait partie de 2,2 de la
conception même de de l'europe qui ne
devaient pas s'occuper des affaires
quotidiennes on s'est aperçu qu'on avait
un problème de souveraineté à la fois
nationale et ce loin des européennes
pour pouvoir s'approvisionner en masques
en produits médicaux en blues et même au
niveau de la recherche
donc il va falloir définir une politique
de recherche avec un budget de recherche
c'est peut-être ce que cette initiative
delà de la présidente peu de démarrer je
veux faire en sorte que la bruxelles et
son propre budget de façon à servir de
catalyseur un petit peu pour que ça vaut
dix fils mais rien ne se fera sans la
volonté politique des différents états
cette volonté politique elle est
peut-être en train contrainte et forcée
de se forger
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre nous
avoir éclairé un sur à cette levée de
fonds donc qu'ils allaient aujourd'hui à
bruxelles
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
éditorialiste économique